[Musik]
hallo frau künast
hallo kommen sie rein ich habe gehört
hier ist fußball hier ist fußball hier
ist richtig remmidemmi
natürlich sehen die wohnung der eltern
habe ich hab's sturmfreie bude und also
falls es so ein bisschen nach gras
riecht er ist mir aber gestern noch da
naja gut habe ich schon hinter mir ja in
der jugend als in den händler jedes
lebensalter hat ja so seine aufgabe oder
gehört kiffen dazu es gab eine
altersgruppe da dachte ich das ist so
real dann habe ich das auch
ordnungsgemäß gemacht was wollen wir
trinken ja ist fußball aber alkoholfreie
also es braucht schon bier damit also
alben holst 30 wir ab der wievielten
flasche tun wir dann so als wären wir
betrunken
ich weiß nicht wie viele brauchen sie
dann wenn es ein heißer sommertag wäre
würde ja vielleicht einreichen um
gefühle zu entwickeln brust
ja ich habe schon das vorbereite
grillgut
das ist seit 1
also wir schicken das jetzt hier rein ja
das ist schon mal sehr pulver nach
belieben nutzen
ja das würde ich auch mal machen aber
tut mir ja keine anderen dazu würde ich
sagen wenn die grillen er das auch mal
ordentlich ist weil ich dachte mir so
bei den grünen da kommt man ja direkt
auf die alten dummen klischees zum vor
tür auf und los nach mit tür auf und los
das ist ja wohl was falsch oder jedoch
das so sein dann können wir gleich
selber so hack würstchen drauf draus
form so kann man sich so ein stück
abreißen ja ganz einfach abreißen so
manches darauf hast es aber immer noch
in der hand der smaghi ja oh nein wie
konnte das passieren
jetzt müssen wir es leider schon rechnen
wir müssen uns leider weg ja ich bin ja
schon weltmeisterlich angezogen und sie
noch nicht aber jetzt dürfen sie sich
frei was aussuchen wir haben alles da
ich habe sogar trikots passend für die
grünen also wegen der farbe gewinnt gut
das ist jetzt saudi arabien an
ja dann immer rhein spaziert hahaha der
perserteppich seien sie nicht zu
kritisch mehr perserteppich ist schon
wieder modern
lassen sie uns über fußball reden hhv
auflösen neu gründen auflösen wenn du da
ein bisschen ruhm reformiert wird auch
nichts besseres oder das ist bei den
grünen nicht auch so er wurde ja auch
viel reformiert und ist besser geworden
weil er jetzt auflösen neuen gründen
seinen berühmten bleibt uns hat er mehr
platz
ach so ich hasse ich habe nichts
vorbereitet hier will grüne snacks grüne
süßigkeiten ist das nicht toll
das sieht ja ein schlimmer aus als das
andere
hallo was sagen sie dazu dass horst
seehofer gesagt habe dass neuer wenige
ausländische bälle rein lassen soll
zwei andere die viel bessere fragen der
wäre nämlich gewesen
vorsichtigen der politisch wer hat den
ball hergestellt zu welchen bedingungen
wie war deren gehalt das ist die frage
machen einige partys wenn die eltern
gehabt sind wir ja aber da lag ich nur
coole leute ein
danke warum können politikerinnen kein
fußball spielen weil es gibt den fc
bundestag ja aber es gibt keinen
weiblichen fc bundestag
vielleicht müssen wir mehr politiker
minister haben ja hier gibt ja mehr als
elf politikerinnen im bundestag können
sie fußball spielen
ich will auch gar nicht wenn du dann
tagelang wochenlang und manchmal von
morgens acht bis morgens um zwei am
nächsten tag mit den allen beieinander
bist dann geht es einem doch wie allen
anderen leuten am arbeitsplatz aber
jetzt will ich auch mal andere leute
sehen und nicht mit denen noch fußball
ja mit denen noch fußball spielen und
zusammen duschen gehen und also ich hab
mal was vorbereitet und zwar ist das so
ein kleines spielchen das man machen
kann wenn man sich ärgert beim wm spiel
wenn deutschland schon wieder verliert
habe ich hier auf dem fernseher eine
zielscheibe wie sie schon sehen ja und
sind schon gespannt was jetzt kommt ja
soll ich jetzt den fernseher kaputt
werfen so ungefähr sehr gut geraten
dann haben wir hier schokoküsse ich
fange an einigen und sogar was für eine
scheiße
ja was machen wir nur auf einmal oder
zweimal deutschland schießt ein tor
[Musik]
wir wollen doch nur die schokoküsse
essen ja so ich es alle die dunkel sind
wahrlich dunkle schokolade wagen der
rest ist für die anderen ja danach
branchenschnitt
jetzt kommt aber das spannende ja jetzt
legen wir unser unserer gemachte von
vorhin drauf klebt jetzt das macht
richtig appetit oder krebs jetzt am holz
wer ist der nächste jahr richtig appetit
man glaubt es nicht man überlege wie man
da draußen habe ich mir das bleibt echt
so kleine das ist eine andere schule es
ist irgendwie muss man das können
wahrscheinlich muss man seiten kochkurs
das belegen blatter weil ich so kleben
wie die dummen tofu gags an den grünen
oder nicht vergessen
deutschland wird weltmeister und damit
zurück ins internet
[Musik]